hey leute wie viele von euch wissen habe
ich ja nun einen neuen pc seit schon
bauer seit wann habe ich den seit
beweise nicht seit zwei drei wochen oder
so und es war mal einige habt ihr doch
mal die shader reihen in hektik und so
weiter und ich bin gar nicht in der
hydro welt also dass hier zählt nicht
als folge
die folge die ich gerade mit komme
aufgenommen habe sollte eigentlich heute
kommen schaffe ich aber nicht mehr wegen
internet problem deswegen kommt die
folge morgen fragt euch dann nicht wenn
ich morgen irgendwie in der folge sage
ja heute kam mit christof blabla ist
halt blöd geplant gewesen
fragt euch da nicht irgendwie hält kann
da gar kein christmas kraft allerdings
wollte ich jetzt einfach so mal noch ein
video hier in exit hochladen und zwar
eine umfrage wo ihr bestimmen könnt
welchen shader ich nehme sollte ich hab
mir jetzt drei schilder runtergeladen
ein normaler shader v2 normaler shader
nur schatten
das ist schade 1 das shader 2 und das
shader 3 und ihr sollt jetzt in die
kommentare schreiben welchen schalter
ich benutzen soll dem hero projekt ich
bin hier gar nicht in der richtigen face
camp nehmen erst mal den ersten shader
ist ihr könnt jetzt 1 2 oder 3 in die
kommentare schreiben ihr könnt auch 12
schreiben oder 13 oder 12 3 das ist euch
ganz egal ist einfach eben bezahlt und
dann werde ich nachher mit seinem
programm wo ich die ganzen also einfach
google chrome dann alle kommentare
anzeigen wenn ich danach gucken welche
kommentare da die welche zahl am meisten
und vorkam
das hier ist ein shader der kerl ist und
er hat dieses komisch wenn ich zum
beispiel so mache jetzt meine füße und
das verwackelte die ganze zeit
ich weiß nicht wer den findet ich finde
ihn jetzt nicht sooo geil aber ihr dürft
ihr bestimmen
also ich finde ihn nicht so geil
allerdings wenn ich mal nach vorne ich
eben zum weiterhin fliege ist hat er
übrigens ein bisschen ich hab damit 30
fps
wenn ich da mal hingucken sieht das echt
hammer geil aus also ich finde der hier
ist ein bisschen so wie stets ein
bisschen verschwommen
ja das ist auf jeden fall die einst dann
kommt es zu zwei den find ich persönlich
so auch schon sehr sehr geil so der ist
allerdings ein bisschen drüber da ist
jetzt quasi jetzt nicht zu richtige
shader mäßiges am start mit dabei
das ist halt shader nummer 2 der liga
zum bisschen trübe aus von der
farbgestaltung aber da ich nachher
enormen farbfilter darüber packe dürfte
keinen so großen unterschied sehen also
für mich sieht es trüber aus aber ich
packe immer noch colour collection und
sättigung und helligkeit kontrast tz
darauf dann sieht das ganze halt noch
ein bisschen schöner auskommt mal die
wolken bewegen sich auch
mein handy bimmelt und hier auf
entfernung sind nicht so toll aus und
shader nummer drei finde ich persönlich
am aller geilsten irgendwie ist so ein
schöner shader so eine schöne mischung
aus den beiden zwar nicht ganz so falsch
aber auch nicht mit diesem komischen
vision dar und weiß nicht also mir
gefällt dieser shader hier persönlich am
besten shader nummer drei ist selbst in
die kommentare schreiben der erste teil
von der farbe farbe bis in heftiger und
der dritte hier dann so ein bisschen
hier so weiß nicht ich finde das ist
viel mehr shader mäßig dass das ganze
als ein bisschen mag ich mag mein
kräftigen wie nicht so wenn das so
richtig aufgepeppt ist ich finde das
sollte irgendwie vor allem hexe zu hero
rolle place ich sollte nicht so was an
schönsten also ich finde nummer drei am
schönsten ihr dürft allerdings bestimmen
ich nehme das was ihr wollt ihr euch am
schönsten passen muss noch mal kurz die
schnell schnelldurchlauf shader nummer
eins wischt ein bisschen zwei heftige
tätigkeit allerdings wenn man sowas
glaub ich abends im bett glücklich von
augenkrebs und das ist halt so ein
bisschen wenn ihr darauf steht dann
schreibt 1 in die kommentare
nummer zwei sehr trübe allerdings auch
schatten hier etc überall die wolken
kann ich aus machen wenn ihr das wollt
ja so sieht das hier halt der shader
nummer 2 aus kein blödes wackeln füße
und so läuft alles auch mehr fps als
beim ersten shader ich laufe jetzt mal
ganz kurz da hinten zu dem baum hin
und das hier ist jeder nummer drei
sondern mischung aus dem ersten beiden
schöne konturen drin helligkeit kann ich
auch immer noch ein wenig hoch stellen
wenn ihr das wollt also ich kann hier
breites wunder machen und sich das ganze
noch mal ein bisschen heller aus ich
finde diesen shader am besten shader
nummer drei habe ich auch meisten apps
mit 35 mehr als 30 grad das auge auch
nicht aufnehmen und vor allem auch der
zahn zieht ja auch keiner da ist die
wüste nicht mehr so hofer am leuchten
sondern das sieht einfach passen einfach
weiß aus na gut da wie ähnliche nach
oder schnee ach das ist sogar schnee
schnee ist das deswegen so weit dass wir
die wüste weit wie sie den sand aus ich
dachte schon wenn der winter da okay das
sieht das schon ganz viel geiler aus der
wüste wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut aus
hier so die schatteneffekte findet
megageil
da wir eben so ein bisschen schnee um
leben finde ich finde es einfach cool
irgendwie so hier sind vom paradies
gleich boxen
ich weiß nicht in wie finde ich das hier
schon recht geil diesen shader die marke
endlich mit am liebsten aber es ist eure
entscheidung schreibt die drei bände
diesen haben wollte dann werde ich das
auswerten
also ich will da zehn milliarden 1000
kommentare sehen welcher remscheider ich
nehme soll und dann wird nicht morgen
der jura folge sondern in der danach
werde ich dann shader benutzen und dann
würde ich sagen es euch gefallen hat
könnt ihr unten hoch geben und dienstag
ist jetzt übrigens immer der tag war
defekt kommen also immer dienstags kommt
jede woche in folge und dann sehen wir
uns dann morgen in die eu wieder oder
war in ihrem video sehen wollte